[Music]
some waving happening um
and welcome back i see some folks are
back
[Music]
all right um and happy monday everyone
so joining me today is nsc coordinator
for strategic communications john kirby
we know there's a lot moving today
so kirby will provide updates on
security assistance for ukraine the
grain exports coming out of odessa and
other foreign policy news of the day
he'll be with us for about 15 minutes or
so and then we'll uh end his portion and
then get to uh the other parts of the
briefing and i'll take some questions
after that everybody okay everybody
settled back there
all right
kirby it's all yours
all right good afternoon everybody just
a few things a few things at the top
today i think you're tracking the first
ship successfully left the port of
odessa in ukraine
under this recent deal between the
united nations turkey ukraine and russia
we obviously welcome this important step
and we hope to see more ships depart in
the coming days to travel onward to
world markets with agricultural products
such as grain wheat sunflower
oil and corn the ship left today had
something like 20 26 000 tons of corn
russia has of course weaponized food
and has effectively blockaded ukraine's
port since the beginning of this crisis
and we urge russia
to meet its commitments under this new
arrangement including by facilitating
unimpeded exports of agricultural
products from black sea ports in order
to ease the food and security around the
world
so we're going to be watching it closely
also on ukraine today national security
adviser jake sullivan the secretary of
state tony blinken uh and the chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff general
mark milley
spoke together with their ukrainian
counterparts about the enduring u.s
support to ukraine as the ukrainian
people continue to stand up to russian
aggression
and to inform them about a new 550
million dollar security assistance
package that the biden administration
will authorize today
this follows secretary austin's call
with his ukrainian counterpart on friday
where he previewed that package today's
announcement is going to include more
ammunition for the high mobility
advanced rocket systems otherwise known
as highmars i know you all are familiar
with that as well as ammunition uh for
the one five five millimeter artillery
systems which have already been
supplied to ukraine and are in the field
this will be the 17th now time that the
bid administration has authorized a
security assistance package using
presidential drawdown authority since
president biden took office and it
brings to more than 8
billion
drawdown authority alone
in material and security assistance for
ukraine just since
the
invasion began in late february
now on taiwan so i know that's on
everybody's mind today
i want to reaffirm
that the speaker has not confirmed any
travel plans and it is for the speaker
to do so and her staff so we won't be
commenting or speculating about um
the stops on her trip
we have been clear from the very
beginning
that she will make her own decisions and
that congress is an independent branch
of government
our constitution embeds the separation
of powers this is well known to the prc
given our more than four decades of
diplomatic relations the speaker has the
right to visit taiwan and the speaker of
the house has visited taiwan before
without incident as have many members of
congress including this year
the world has seen the united states
government be very clear that nothing
has changed nothing has changed
about our one china policy which is of
course guided by the taiwan relations
act
the three joint usprc communiques and
the six assurances
we have said
we have repeatedly said
that we oppose any unilateral changes to
the status quo from either side
we have said that we do not support
taiwan independence
and we have said that we expect
cross-strait differences to be resolved
by peaceful
means we have communicated this directly
to the prc at the highest levels
including as recently as last week in a
phone call between president biden and
president xi
the national security adviser the
secretary of state defense the chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff have also
made this very clear to beijing in a
half a dozen recent high-level
conversations
put simply
there is no reason for beijing to turn a
potential visit consistent with
long-standing u.s policy into some sort
of crisis or conflict
or use it as a pretext to increase
aggressive military activity in
or around the taiwan strait
and yet
over the weekend even before speaker
pelosi arrived in the region china
conducted a live fire exercise
china appears to be positioning itself
to potentially take further steps in the
coming days
and perhaps over longer time horizons
these potential steps from china could
include military provocations such as
firing missiles in the taiwan strait or
around taiwan
operations that break historical norms
such as large-scale air entry into
taiwan's air defense identification zone
adiz i think you all know that acronym
air or naval activities that cross the
median line and military exercises that
could be highly publicized
this could also include actions in the
diplomatic and economic space such as
further spurious legal claims by
beijing's public assertions last month
i'm sorry like
beijing's public assertions last month
that the taiwan strait is not an
international waterway
some of these actions would continue
concerning trend lines that we've seen
in recent years but some
could be of a different scope and scale
the last time beijing fired missiles
into the taiwan strait was 1995 and 1996
after beijing reacted provocatively to
taiwan's president's visit
to deliver an address at his alma mater
i want to contrast this now between the
united states and china we
and countries around the world believe
escalation serves no one
beijing's actions could have unintended
consequences that only serve to increase
tensions
meanwhile our actions are not
threatening and they break
no new ground
nothing about this potential visit
potential visit which oh by the way has
precedent
would change the status quo
and the world should reject any
prc effort to use it to do so
we will not take the bait or engage in
saber rattling
at the same time we will not be
intimidated
we will keep operating in the seas and
the skies of the western pacific as we
have for decades
we will continue to support cross-strait
peace stability support taiwan of course
defend a free and open indo-pacific and
we're still going to seek to maintain
lines of communication with beijing
all of that is important and all of that
all of it is preserving the status quo
we expect to see beijing continue to use
inflammatory rhetoric and disinformation
in the coming days united states by
contrast
will act with transparency
we'll stand up here we'll answer your
questions we'll give you the facts
we are also committed to keeping open
lines of communication with beijing as i
said this is what the world expects of
not just the united states but of china
and we encourage beijing to keep that
commitment as well
with that go to some questions
thanks john so
given all the saber rattling that's
being done by china and the fact that
speaker pelosi is still considering a
trip the fact that you're laying out all
the possible reactions that china could
have should we take this as a sort of
test of china's willingness to make good
on some of its designs on taiwan or a
test of whether they've learned some of
the lessons that
that russia learned by ukraine invading
ukraine
the short answer to your question and
then i promise i won't just leave it
with a short answer is that's a that's a
better question for president xi
um and what's in his mind uh over this
i think we've laid out very clearly that
if she goes
if she goes it's not without precedent
it's not new it doesn't change anything
i mean
what we would hope
[Music]
they
infer from everything we've done and
everything we've said including during
the president's phone call is that we're
being consistent there's no change we
we've not ramped up the rhetoric we've
not changed our behavior everything
we've done is consistent with our
obligations and our commitments but if
the policy hasn't changed then why was
the speaker being urged not to go
i don't know that she was urged not to
go who urged her not to go the president
said on august 20th that the military
doesn't think it's a good idea for her
speaker makes her own decisions what
we did was provide her context
analysis facts information so that she
could make the best decision uh possible
for
every stop for every overseas travel and
again i'm not going to get ahead of her
or her staff here with respect to the
rest of this trip does the us military
still think it's not a good idea i would
refer you to the the military again
we as a national security team not just
dod
we are obligated and we take that
obligation seriously to make sure she
has all the contacts she needs before
she travels overseas and and we did that
and oh by the way we'll continue to do
that throughout the remainder of her
trip uh for for anything else that she
needs uh to make sure she has a
successful visit russia
john
thank you you've been emphasizing the
separation of powers and the separation
of the legislative branch from the
executive does the white house feel
confident that president xi understands
that separation
as i said in my opening statement
uh
we
we've had
you know
diplomatic and bilateral
relations with the prc for decades they
understand well
i can't speak for
president xi i wouldn't do that but our
assumption is they understand very well
how our constitution is organized and
that there are three equal branches of
government
you know i don't think i'm hearing you
say
yes to that question and i said it in my
opening statement that the the prc
understands well the separation of
powers um if if you are confident about
that
was this an issue that president biden
raised directly with president xi during
their phone call we didn't get a very
detailed readout of the detailed
discussions they had during that phone
call last week the president in his
conversation with the president xi
[Music]
made clear that congress is an
independent branch of government and
that
speaker pelosi
makes her own decisions as other members
of congress do about their overseas
travel that was made clear can i just do
one more follow-up if the policy is that
the president
wouldn't encourage or discourage a
lawmaker from traveling to a specific
place because of the separation
if a senior lawmaker were to plan a trip
right now to say north korea or moscow
would we not hear the president weigh in
in those instances i think you would see
the president be consistent
we provide members of congress
fax analysis context they make their own
decisions about
where and when they're going to travel
we do the best we can to provide advice
and counsel and context and information
and that will continue there's nothing
inconsistent about that at all i just
realized i have my badge on i got to
take this
uh
has anyone in the administration
are in this white house explicitly
spoken with the speaker and said you
should not go on the ship i know the
president has not done that but has
there been any communication from senior
national security officials inside this
white house there have been direct
conversations with the speaker and her
staff before she left at various levels
uh in the national security
establishment the president did not
speak directly with the speaker about
this trip
i am not going to divulge the contents
of those conversations that we have i
mean with her particularly with the
speaker
i will just go back to what i said
before tyler
fulsome discussions
context analysis facts information
about her overseas travel which is
completely consistent with the way we do
it in the past
it seems like this trip obviously is
sparking a little bit more anxiety
inside this building and throughout the
administration and i understand that you
said the president respects the
independence but given the national
security risks that play in china's
escalating rhetoric was there not a
discussion inside this administration
about whether or not you should take a
more urgent census as mj just alluded to
if there were other countries that play
here we might see a different response
given what china has said it might do in
response to a trip that puts all
americans at risk in their national
security did the president feel that
maybe this is a different case that he
should be more involved or his team
should be more involved than him i mean
again i'm not going to get into the
details of the conversation
they were comprehensive discussions
about
uh about what she wanted to achieve on
this trip where she wanted to go
and we provided her the same set of
contexts and information that that we
have in the past with respect to her
overseas travel i'm not going to get
into the details of that
[Music]
thank you um
i guess i'm wondering why did the
president bother with this drama from
the beginning i mean
why not rather than saying the military
doesn't think it's a good idea to go
why not call the chinese bluffer or tell
them to pound sand when they started
bellyaching about the possibility of
this trip given as you pointed out
there's no change in policy and there's
precedent for pelosi to visit taiwan so
what's the drama what what have you
watched the braves last couple of weeks
i mean there's been this question yeah
i've been here the last couple of weeks
i haven't seen any drama i think
i think you're manufacturing it with
your question look we have been nothing
but clear
um
with the chinese uh about
where we stand on the issues and the one
china policy and our support for a free
and indo uh free and open indo-pacific
look i want to go back to what i said to
at the beginning because
and i hope you took note
nothing has changed there's no drama to
talk to it is not without president for
a speaker of the house to go to taiwan
if she goes and i'm not confirming that
she is
and it's certainly not without president
for members of congress to travel to
taiwan it has been done this year and
i'm certain that it will be done in the
future
we have no interest
as i said in my opening statement
increasing tensions here we have no
interest in changing any other approach
approach that we take as a government
or in keeping with our allies and
partners to uh to wanting to see
cross-strait tensions
be resolved peacefully without a
unilateral change so
i don't know about the drama that you've
your your claimant exists um it's quite
the contrary here
and the point that we have made
i made it again today and president
biden made it with president xi
everything here is consistent there's no
reason to use a potential visit
to
to uh
to justify or to spark some sort of
crisis or conflict
we certainly aren't have no interest in
that and there's
no justification to to use a potential
visit as a pretext to conduct what could
be escalatory measures such as the ones
i detailed in the opening statement
hi john you keep saying that the speaker
um has the right to make her own
decision and another speaker visited
before which i believe you talked about
cambridge when he visited
but it's different timing there's more
tension and the speaker represents the
president's party so while she has the
right to make the wrong decision why can
we say that the white house disagree
with her decision because that will
cause more attention let's just say that
categorically now that she basically um
the white house disagree with her visit
me
i'm sorry but you're asking me why i
can't just say we disagree with the
visit correct because it might for all
the conversation will just have it now
it would cause more attention all right
so two things
one
there's been no
discussion by the the speaker about
what's next on her trip so
you're you're asking me a question as if
she's already somehow confirmed that
she's going to taiwan i haven't seen any
such confirmation and again i would
point you to
uh
the speaker and her staff uh to talk
about her uh her itinerary
um and number two again
our responsibility is to make sure that
she and her team have all the
information they need and we keep that
line of communication throughout
a trip as we should of course it's a
requirement
but the speaker and her staff who
advises her they make the decision so um
you guys seem to be or your question
seems to presume that that we should
have
uh
you know
stamped the trip with some sort of
approval or disapproval that's not the
way this works congress is an
independent branch of government can you
confirm if she's trying if she's
traveling on commercial flights or is
she going officially on a government
thing because that will be interpreted
by the chinese differently it's not this
what we see is a common place for the
speaker to travel aboard a u.s military
transport aircraft
very typical
has the administration been in touch
with the chinese government since the
president's last conversation with
president xi i'm sorry say that again
has the administration people in the
administration been in touch with the
chinese government since the president's
uh conversation i'm not aware of any
specific communications after that call
what planning is being done in advance
to ensure that there won't be any
dangerous fallout if she does indeed go
to taiwan well without getting into
details i think you can understand that
part of our
responsibilities is to make sure that
she can travel safely and securely and i
can assure you that she will
what about russia what about russia
banning a jewish agency absolutely
certainly
let korean please let korean call in
terms of the um
the speaker's
agenda and her motivation for going
which does seem to be
different than the president's set of
issues since he has said publicly the
military doesn't think it's a good idea
he has not come out and given a fulsome
support for uh this trip if it happens
what is your sense about her advocacy
for
democracy for self-rule
in taipei if she were to go there and
the impact of that if she were to make
that kind of a statement long-held views
on the part of the speaker and how that
might have an impact well the speaker
can speak for herself
and
whatever
she
wants to say on this trip is really her
prerogative
that's why it was so important for me
and my opening comments kelly to make
clear what this administration's policy
is with respect to the one china
principle when sorry when china policy
as well as um
as not wanting to see cross-strait
tensions
resolved
by any than other than peaceful means
and the fact that we don't support
taiwan independence it was important for
me to lay that down right at the outset
that's
our policy that's this administration's
approach i can't speak for what speaker
pelosi
may do or say on this trip okay one
question here if i may follow up
um
because of the closeness between the
speaker and the president
it does raise the question about
is she
sort of pressing a foreign policy that
may in fact put the president in a bad
position
is that the sense of this white house
the president is comfortable with the
position that this administration
continues to take which has long
standing
historic precedence and i went through
it all with the opening statement the
president is very comfortable uh with uh
with our policy with respect to
to china
into taiwan and he had an opportunity
last week to reaffirm
those policies and his views in his
direct discussion with president xi just
a few more jeff and then joey thank you
very much
john you mentioned the potential of
missile launches by china are the people
of taiwan at risk if peter pelosi makes
this visit and is she at risk if she
makes this visit we certainly don't
think there's any
reason for
anybody to be at risk here with a
a potential visit again hasn't been uh
announced then i won't speak uh for uh
speaker pelosi but there's certainly no
reason for this to come to blows there's
certainly no reason for this to
to escalate um
um and
as for the potential risks
i think
that is a
better question put to the prc
and to the pla army and navy and the air
force
we're going to watch this very very
closely we're going to make sure that
she has a safe and secure
visit because that's our responsibility
and we urge as i said at the outset we
urge
china to
if she goes to see this
for exactly what it is
nothing new
no change to our policy and certainly
not an unprecedented uh visit by the
speaker of the house you also said the
us will not be intimidated
do you feel that using language like
that right now will be viewed by china
in a
in a way that you are also raising
rhetoric the way they have
you said it right at the top like that
they have
there they have been out there uh in
recent days uh with some irresponsible
rhetoric
we feel it's important
for
for everybody in the region to
understand how seriously we take our
security commitments in the indo-pacific
and that's why we put it that way
there's no reason jeff for this to
honestly there's just no reason for this
to escalate
and
in fact there's
there's every reason given
the
our national security interests as well
as the interests of our allies and
partners that that are at stake in the
indo-pacific on any given day
there's every reason for this uh to not
escalate um and for the lines of
communication to remain open between
washington and beijing and that's what
we'd like to see happen
on iran
thanks john uh does the white house
currently know whether speaker pelosi is
planning to go to taiwan i realize she's
not announced anything publicly you've
also said white house officials have
been talking to the speakers uh staff so
does the white house currently have
knowledge whether she is planning to go
to taiwan i am not going to talk about
the
speaker's itinerary i'm just not going
to do that and jeff i want to go back to
one other thing if i may
because it was in my mind and i flew out
of my mind as i was answering your
question is
when you talk about or yet
threaten
these kinds of potential operations
military operations and
exercises and missile launches that i
talked about i mean
what that does is it does increase the
risk of miscalculation as i said and
which could lead to unintended
consequences and and that's really the
risk to your you ask specifically are
they at risk
that's where the risk comes in it's it's
not so much
uh that there might be a direct attack
but it raises the stakes of
miscalculation and confusion which could
also lead to unintended consequences
okay darlene and i'm going to take some
in the back
[Music]
given everything that you've laid out
here
why do you think china is reacting the
way it is reacting to this speaker and
this trip
it's difficult to know
specifically and you're kind of asking
me to get inside their brains and i
don't know that i'm comfortable doing
that i i think again that's a
a question better put to president xi
and uh
uh and the prc and their and their
military leaders um
there has been you've heard chairman
millie talk about this
[Music]
even before we were talking about a
potential visit by the speaker of
increasing
aggressiveness
by pla military forces in the region
alone
violations
in air and sea space across the street
more
aggressive uh and proximate military
exercises um and of course
in their rhetoric i mean this has been
going on now for months and if you
really wanna you can go back years in
terms of uh chinese coercion and
intimidation
tactics even just in the military
environment
in the south china sea east china sea so
been building
i can't account for
why
they
have answered the
just the possibility of this visit in
the in the manner in which they've done
i can only account
for president biden and for this
administration and for how we are trying
uh
to
manage tensions and quite frankly manage
this one of the most consequential
bilateral relationships in the world and
that is by
making it clear
what we're seeing
sharing it with you
uh making it clear that there's no
reason
for whatever the reason is
there's no reason that
it should spark some kind of conflict or
that it should precipitate
increased tensions or
serve as some sort of pretext
for some sort of what they would
consider a
reaction
if the speaker goes
completely consistent with what's been
done in the past
and certainly not at all a statement
about any change
to american policy with respect to one
china and to and to cross straight
tensions and quite frankly to our
obligations under the law to continue to
support taiwan's self-defense
if she does go to taiwan how will the
white house find out about it will she
call someone on the nasdaq team will you
see it on television
how will you know well look uh the
speaker's flying aboard a military
aircraft so we'll know
all right we're just going to do two in
the back and then we got to wrap it up
go ahead
[Music]
you talk about the separation of the
congressman and the white house and the
executive branch but when she takes a
military aircraft how then do you which
is under the control of the president
how do you make the case that well we
had nothing to do with this at all
i didn't say we had nothing to do with
this at all and no we've never said that
at all we
from the time
she informed us that she was going to go
overseas
we put the gears in motion like we
always do and that is to provide
military transportation nothing new
about that provider team with
information context you've heard me
you've heard kareem talk about that
nothing new about that i mean it's not
that we're not involved but we don't
make the decision for the speaker she
makes her own decisions we give her
advice and counsel in context she makes
her own decisions and the president
having long served in the senate himself
he understands and respects
the institutional prerogatives of
members of congress all right
all the way in the back
of the korean oh thanks karine um i have
a quick question about the
iranian-american dissident journalist
marcie
alina during an interview on cnn this
morning she called on the
administration to expel iranian
diplomats contending the regime has now
twice challenged the us government on
u.s soil alluding to the kidnap plot
um last year and then the arrest last
week of a man near her home with a
loaded rifle is that something that the
white house is
even considering or if there are other
diplomatic levers the president is
prepared to pull
there's
there's somewhat of a limit to what we
can say on that so let me just
lay it out for you we
the united states condemns the apparent
attempt to harm
leading iranian activists and u.s
citizen macia linded at her home in new
york last week
we commend law enforcement swift and
effective response to this apparent
threat to her
this is an open criminal investigation
and so i'm going to refer you to law
enforcement for any further comment
while we wait to see the results of that
investigation
we do want to reaffirm
that it is a first priority for the
biden administration to counter the
threat posed by iran including
against dissidents that are living in
the united states and current and former
u.s government officials
okay thank you everybody
appreciate it thank you
[Music]
all right thanks john
[Music]
all right just have one thing at the top
gas prices
um just to provide you all an update on
where we are currently uh with gas
prices uh we have now been falling for
almost seven straight weeks
uh as of this morning gas prices have
dropped 81
cents per gallon since their peak in
june as you'll see from the chart
to my left here
that means american families who who
with two cars are saving eighty dollars
a month
drivers can now find gas for 399
or less
at around half of all gas stations
across the country and average gasoline
prices have come below 399 in 19 states
putin's war is still putting pressure on
global oil supply but president biden is
taking historic action to mitigate its
impacts on american families he is
releasing one million barrels of oil a
day from the strategic petroleum reserve
which is a historic
action that he's taken he rallied global
partners to release millions of barrels
of oil and under president biden u.s oil
production is up and track and on track
to reach a record high
the treasury department estimates that
the historic release of oil by president
biden and international partners has
reduced gas prices by up to about 40
cents per gallon as we have shared with
you all last week
more work remains but the fact is that
we are currently experiencing the
fastest decline in gas prices in over a
decade and with that darlene
oh
the first time you tested positive the
white house had identified 17 contacts
can you update us on those and then were
there any occasional contacts from him
testing positive again over the weekend
that we should be aware of so those 17
are uh continue to test negative so
that's the update on the the first
positive test that the president had
that we shared with all of you
uh
with this
positive test that we
saw and shared with all of you again on
saturday there's been seven i mean not
seven i apologize six uh close contacts
and those uh those six individuals uh
continue to test negative
has he resumed the blood-thinning
medication that he had stopped when he
was on high school he has resumed uh all
the medication that he was on the
medication that he was on before and one
final question quickly there was video
of him yesterday facetiming with the
folks the veterans camping out on
capitol hill we haven't seen anything
from him today
can you give us a sense of how he's
doing
with having to go back into isolation
meaning he's
frustrated
and how is he dealing with being away
from the first lady for as long as he
can well the day's still young you never
know
um but um look the president
i'm just
just making a joke
clearly it was not funny
i will try harder next time to be more
funny um but um
look he is continuing to work from the
residence
and i just want to share
as we all know the president is fully
vaccinated he's fully he's double
boosted he was on treatment for pax
lovid
and
and because of that treatment he had
very mild symptoms and we had said with
pax love it there would be a small
percentage of uh of folks do have a
relapse this is what we saw uh but he's
doing well you you saw him as you said
darlene uh and he said he's fine he
sounded great
and he's looking as we know he is he's
someone who likes to be out there with
the american people he's looking forward
to being out there
again and um uh yeah but he's going to
continue it doesn't stop him from doing
his job and doing the work of the
american people so he is uh in the white
house resident and he's going to
continue to do that uh as he uh isolates
for a couple more days
a couple of clarification points on that
uh dr o'connor said today that the
president's feeling fine
but he didn't mention symptoms can you
clarify on whether he's even
experiencing any minor symptoms
congestion
so he is not experiencing we haven't
seen any reoccurring symptoms that was
in dr o'connor's letter on saturday so
that continues to be true i spoke to dr
o'connor uh not too long before coming
out uh to talk to all of you as you know
some of you have had kovitz some of you
have loved ones and close close friends
who have had covid those symptoms that
you have don't don't go away right away
they kind of linger those minimal
symptoms kind of linger for some time so
you could expect that
and so with that but there's no no
reoccurring symptoms he's he's actually
he's feeling fine the uh cdc guidelines
on the so-called pax limited rebound are
a little unclear can you clarify on what
the expectation is of how long the
president will continue to isolate is it
uh five days after the rebound positive
is it are we looking at another sort of
clear set of clock and ten days out from
the rebound positive what's the guidance
on that so he's going to abide by cdc
recommendations so it would be five days
as far as the isolation
thursday from the
rebound they'll rebound right on
saturday yes
you're about to get yeah
going back and forth and then um
were you able to get a sense of the
president's reaction to senator manchin
uh yesterday repeatedly refusing to get
behind an endorsement for a re-election
um and does the president if he did get
a reaction to that uh feel like
members of his own party are undermining
him on that front i mean you know i saw
those interviews i i wouldn't say he was
undermining from what it looked like to
me
senator manchin is very much focused uh
he went on he went on the the shows to
to focus on the uh the inflation
reduction act he was very he was zeroed
in on that and laid out
why this is going to be a benefit for
middle class families and why it's going
to lower costs and why it is an
investment a historic investment uh in
in in
you know that we have not seen a long
time whether it's climate change or uh
or just in general as we try to reduce
inflation and fight that back and you
and figure out how do we continue to
lower the deficit and so repeatedly
asked whether he would support president
biden in 2024
and he repeatedly
okay so here's here's what i say i'll
say about this and you know we from from
the podium i really cannot dive into any
election uh but i've been really clear
and the president's been asked this
question many times and he intends uh to
run in 2024 he plans to run in 2024 that
is way off like we are we are a long
ways away uh from 2024 and here's the
thing our biggest thing right now is to
not be distracted uh you saw chips uh
passed last week which is going to be a
huge investment in manufacturing and low
in uh really strengthening the supply
chain was just talking about national
security so strengthen our national
security huge deal and now what we we
still have a few things
ahead of us uh that's going to be really
important to get that done uh for for
the american people so we're going to
stay focused and so we're not going to
be distracted and that's that's how we
see things at this time gotcha uh it's
great a follow-up on the covet
topic
is it possible that the president in his
understandable desire to show that he
was able to work through his first
bottom folded
push himself too hard and that is
partially what led to this coming again
i mean any
body being 79 or
worthy 6 has to rest when you get this
no
uh
just to answer that very um so look you
know uh
we were we were transparent that we were
aware that when it comes to paxlovid
that there is a small chance right
there's a small chance of relapse uh it
is not uncommon uh it does happen
and here's the thing the parent the
president according to his doctor had
very mild symptoms uh and so we don't
think that he you know he overexerted
himself or was the right wrong decision
it was it was because of how he was
doing
at the time and so again we were
transparent about what we thought could
potentially happen
uh and uh you know and we also were
transparent that if he were to test uh
positive again i have or have that
relapse he would share it which we did
and uh and now he's feeling fine uh he's
doing well he's doing the business of
the american people in the white house
residents and he's looking forward to to
to be out here again and one other topic
um what's the next step from the white
house perspective on the
inflation reduction act do you and have
you had any
signals from
senator cinema as to whether or not she
will support it so i'm
not going to get into details about any
conversations that we're having with
congressional members
i will say and i've said this before our
white house staff
white house officials here continue to
be in touch
with folks in the house and offering any
technical assistance offering any
guidance that folks might need there so
we'll continue to do that
and you know i'll i'll leave it to
senator manchin who spoke to that and
was again was asked many questions about
uh senator cinema so i'll leave it to
him in that conversation as the
negotiations negotiations are occurring
i wanted to ask about new york city
declaring a public health emergency as
it relates to monkey talks over the
weekend does the administration
generally support local municipalities
taking this kind of action as they see
fit that these are their own decisions
to make i we see that as their own
decisions to make uh clearly it's a
local jurisdiction it's for them to to
figure out what's going on in their own
community they know best uh of what's
happening on the ground so we leave that
to them i do want to i do want to add so
because we do have some news on on the
vaccinations that i've mentioned
the jnos vaccination that were that was
announced
last week on thursday 737 000 vaccines
are out
as as i'm speaking in front of you right
now they're being shipped uh to uh to
areas that really need to to areas that
really need them and so if you think
about the 777
thirty seven thousand seven seven thirty
seven hundred thirty seven thousand uh
and the three hundred thousand plus that
we have put out that puts one point one
million uh doses that's out in the
united states and so that matters it's
very important is as we're trying to
really have a aggressive approach
to dealing with monkey pox on testing
and i don't know folks had this but we
are doing testing about 80 000 tests per
week
and that's another important significant
way of making sure that people are
getting tested so they know uh
if they have monkey pox or not and
lastly and i've talked about this from
here already which is the education
which is the outreach
educating a
public health officials and activists
out there making sure that they know
exactly what to look for and what the
treatment is and so that as well
continues do you have any insight on the
president's own thinking right now on
the possibility of declaring a national
public emergency on this i know he'll
obviously be advised by
folks around him including secretary
sarah but what does he think so when it
comes to a public health emergency that
is a decision that
that is made by uh secretary becerra
that is not made by the president but as
you know we are considering every policy
option uh to help end this outbreak uh
that is uh urgent and that is important
to us uh but again that is up to uh
secretary percera to make that decision
any general timeline i i would i would
uh refer you to hhs on the specific
timeline
go ahead frankly i've been calling you
before thanks so much
i'm just curious if there's any concern
about the president's rebound case
uh concerned that that could set back
any efforts to get people to take or for
pax love it to be prescribed for severe
cases absolutely not the way we see it
is uh paxlovit has over 90 percent
chance of preventing severe illness if
it's taken early
and you know as we saw the president had
very mild symptoms uh because of
paxlovid because he was fully vaccinated
because he was double boosted and so uh
we we anticipated that we had said there
would be a minimal chance
of him having a relapse and so you know
again you know the relapse uh truly uh
is is
and and the protection of pax love it
easily outweighs that
as we see it uh and so again you know we
encourage uh americans out there who
haven't uh fully get gotten vaccinated
to do that who haven't been boosted to
go ahead and get their booster the
treatment that the president
received is the same treatment that
others could receive as well and that is
because of the work that this
administration that this president has
done from day one walking into the white
house what about russia
also if i could ask i know uh you're a
little tired of asking about 20 or
answering questions about 2024 oh i'm
never tired
and running uh whether he will run i
just you know with with former president
trump talking about submitting his
paperwork uh but potentially before the
midterms why when will president biden
file his paperwork and wouldn't that
help kind of nip some of these questions
in the budget i mean the president has
said that he intends to run
he's he said that multiple times
uh so there's that i'll put that out
there um but again we are we have some
you know we have some work to do uh in
the next couple of days and weeks that
we're going to focus on we're not going
to be distracted
by what's happening
with the former president that is not
our focus
our focus right now is you know as we're
talking about the inflation
reduction act which is which is historic
as i just laid out which is incredibly
important as we talk about lowering cost
prescription drugs for our seniors as
we're talking about getting some of that
energy lowering costs
on energy
for
families who are sitting around their
kitchen table trying to figure out how
are they going to
pay for whatever item that that is
incredibly important to them so this is
what this is going to do and so we're
going to continue to talk about that
we see that we see the uh influen
inflation reduction act as a down
payment as a promise that we the
president has made and uh and so we're
going to continue to make sure we get
that over the finish
line um just a question about the
president's copic case uh and guidelines
you outlined that he'll be in isolation
for five days how does that relate to
potential travel i know that
even if you test negative there are cdc
guidelines that discourage you from
traveling for a certain period of time
does that clock start back at zero with
the rebound so the travel is is a little
bit uh different because there there
there are no cdc recommendations on uh
regarding travel for rebound
so that does not exist in this
for rebound cases so as far as travel i
just don't have anything to share with
for you right now but right now cdc
doesn't have any recommendations for for
for a rebound on cases operating under
the
assumption that when and if the
president tests negative then he will
both be cleared to return to work in the
office and travel wherever so we're
going to do the i just mentioned the
isolation uh five days he's clearly he's
going to be testing
regularly one of the reasons right one
of the reasons that we were able uh to
share with you that he tested positive
is because we upped his testing cadence
because of his unique role right as
president we wanted to make sure uh that
we were keeping an eye on that and so
that's why we were able to share uh that
testing his uh his test his him testing
positive on on saturday uh so we'll
continue to do that but as far as travel
there's just no cdbc recommendation once
we have more uh
we will let you know
i'm just wondering is the white house
plan that as soon as he tests negative
he can
he can return to all activities
that's that's that that is our hope that
is our expectation but we are going to
follow as i just mentioned uh cdc
guidance as it relates to isolation and
just one last one on the president's
schedule last week when before he tested
negative you guys gave us a more fulsome
readout of what he was doing yeah what
meetings he had we've received nothing
today can you give us some sort of uh is
he on the phone with lawmakers and this
economic team is probably team what is
the present day again the day is young
but uh so we um i i know on friday we
provided his meetings um he which would
included
dealing with the awful flooding in
kentucky and helping provide federal
resources working working with governor
bashir and senator mcconnell speaking
with members of congress and meeting
with his senior staff
he will be doing a lot of that work
virtually as we have done in the past
and and so i mean the work doesn't stop
he'll just continue to do that what he's
done today well he'll be meeting with
senior staff for sure that is something
that's pretty regular on his schedule so
i can for sure uh share that with you if
there's anything else to read out uh we
will be uh we will share we'll share
that with you good thanksgiving is
president biden thinking about pulling
his support for the inflation reduction
act
no
because he promised it wasn't going to
make that it wasn't going to raise taxes
on anybody making less than 400 thousand
dollars a year but the
joint committee on taxation says that is
not true
well that is incorrect
so
the joint committee on taxation which
you guys
heralded as a an effective body when
you're selling that infrastructure
package
is not to be trusted here
i said it is not correct because i will
give you why it's not correct because it
is incomplete uh the jct uh
report that we're currently seeing is
incomplete because it omits
the actual benefits
that americans would receive when it
comes to prescription drugs when it
comes comes to
the end lowering energy costs like
utility bills it does not include that
and
we have some experts don't have to trust
me we have experts that say the exact
same kimberly kimberly clausing from
ucla many key factors are left out
in these tables including importantly
the effect of deficit reduction the
positive effects of the spending on
clean energy and the benefits from low
drug prices that i just stated seth
holland center for american progress
republicans don't mention that jct
analysis includes an in imputation of
corporate taxes i.e the 15 percent
minimum
on corporations with
less than 1 billion of profits to income
groups but does not include the major
provisions that benefit people including
the tax cuts and uh drug uh savings
prescription drug space savings to be
specific so penn wharton where president
used to
uh
university of pennsylvania used to be a
professor there pam wharton budget model
says this inflation reduction act is
actually going to increase
inflation in 2024 does the president
worry about that so we agree with
senator manchin you heard him a couple
times yesterday and disagree with penn
wharton as a as as as do a number of
qualified experts which i'm happy to
read out but i you know i do want to say
that it is quite ironic
that
congressional republicans are
complaining or are uh have a false a
false outrage
on on this inflation reduction act that
is actually going to do something and
help the american people lower cost
when you know when they have offered
really nothing to do that uh what they
have offered is to increase taxes on
americans making less than a hundred
thousand uh dollars a year and what they
have uh introduced is actually
sunsetting medicare and sunsetting
also
social security after five years and
that's how they want to
deal with uh how to help the american
people we are talking about doing the
complete absolute complete opposite and
just one more it's been three days now
since a chinese official publicly
threatened to murder speaker pelosi
where is the president
coming out to respond to at the very
least say don't do that well first we've
talked
kirby was just here talking about how um
i have not seen those reports so i'm
just going to say they were going to
maybe shoot down her plane or that they
would it would be within their rights
well we have talked about that we have
said that there's no need for this type
of saber rattling it is unnecessary the
president has been very clear there's
been no change
in the
one china policy
we continue to support the taiwan
relations act
what we are seeing
from
from
you know what we're talking about right
now and to be clear uh the speaker has
not confirmed as you heard from my
colleague just moments ago uh that she
is going to taiwan it has not been
confirmed
and uh you
know the history of this of
congressional members going to taiwan is
not uncommon it is something that has
happened in the past uh and and so again
nothing has changed and the president
has made that very very clear okay
there's two more bits of pushback on the
inflation reduction act sure right farm
is running ads in this town and probably
others it says that uh the
pay for when it comes to medicare and
allowing medicare to negotiate some
prescription drugs will result in money
coming out of the medicare system and
the
research and development perhaps being
crypt
there's also the national association of
manufacturers which says that the pay
for the 15 minimum corporate tax is
essentially a tax on domestic
manufacturing because it would in some
ways target the accelerated depreciation
that many factory owners use to pay for
equipment um does the president is the
president confident that
the if passed and enacted the bill will
neither
affect
the medicare program and the way the
drugs are developed in this country or
his goal is to increase domestic
manufacturing so i'll say this there are
55 companies corporations in this
country who make tens of billions of
dollars who aren't paying zero who are
paying zero
uh dollars when it comes to taxes so
this bill is going to fix that tax
loophole
and make the tax code fairer and that
matters and when you think about what
that's going to do you think about that
300 billion dollars that's going to go
uh towards uh deficit making sure that
we continue to bring down
the deficit 1.7 trillion dollars we saw
from last year add another 300 billion
dollars that is going to save cost
that's going to save costs for the
american people and that is so critical
so important especially as we're talking
about inflation and high costs right now
and so as it relates to medicare just
want to just say like the aarp who you
all know and advocacy group for seniors
has endorsed
this piece of piece of legislation
while the limit of cost of medicines and
cap out of pocket expenses to 2000 a
year for people on medicare it will
limit that which is so important for
many seniors this will also strengthen
medicare by reducing its expenses which
save tax taxpayers money and helps fight
inflation and so that is
really important these are the things uh
if you ask a family and you say to them
what are some of the costs that you want
us to bring down what are the things
that really hit your pocketbook they
will say prescription drugs many will
say one of those things are prescription
drugs and so this is a historic
investment that's going to make that
it's going to
just be a game changer for families that
is incredibly important and that's what
the president cares about and that's how
the president wants to continue to
support this legislation one question
about the president's covet case
given the importance of getting him back
on a regular schedule was there any
discussion here about taking any
additional steps to try to help him
clear the virus faster and putting it
back on pakistan
giving him more fluids i don't sleep
more anything like that i don't have
anything more than what the what what
his physician shared uh today and also
the last couple of days to all of you
how how he's feeling he's feeling very
fine he's doing great we heard from him
directly say that um and we expect it
again we expected with pax love it to be
a relapse it's not unusual it's common
we shared that with all of you the last
couple of days uh during his uh during
his his his about with kovid
and so
again this is not unusual he's feeling
fine uh we will continue to share
an update from his physician
you'll get one tomorrow and and so we're
just going to continue with what the
doctor lays out and takes his take his
word for it
um what will the president sign the
ship's bill is that something that he'll
do while he's isolating is that
something he's going to do when he can
resume travel
yeah we will have something on that very
very soon i don't have anything for you
at this time we'll have something on
that for you one more question has the
u.s received an official answer yet from
russia on
its offer of our prisoner swap
so uh we have uh we've talked about this
the last couple of days look as you know
we want to see brittany griner home we
want to see paul whalen home they are
wrongfully detained we have been very
clear about that we put forward a
substantial offer
and
we you know we want to have a good faith
uh conversation on that we want to
make sure that we get this done as soon
as possible
what we have heard uh as you've heard
from my colleagues is in bad faith uh it
is uh
and so
you know is it's not a serious there was
a counteroffer that was made which we
don't see it as a serious uh counter
offer uh clearly not going to negotiate
from here not going to get into uh any
specific details but as you can see from
uh the substantial offer as you can hear
from secretary blinken and as you've
heard from this president we are taking
this very seriously and this is a top of
mind for this president and we want to
see them come home about russia
uh one more on the president's case you
had referred to the physician letter
that says no re-emergency symptoms but
you also said lingering symptoms
so help us square that so we understand
yeah well no reoccurring symptoms uh
meaning like if you look at his original
letter there's nothing um
uh there's nothing like
severe right because he feels fine right
he feels he feels good but as we know
when all of us have had covet you do
have a little bit of a lingering cough
right you do have a little bit of maybe
a lingering sniffles that's not uncommon
to have and so that's what we are
talking about so he is not 100 symptom
free he just didn't have like a fever
return or something like that
well he never had a i want to be careful
because we were we went into this about
if he had a fever or not he never had a
fever so i wanted to be really clear his
it was elevated but it was never a fever
but remember there were we had talked
about a little fatigue we had talked
about aches you know that he was he was
there was a little bit of discomfort so
that has not uh that has not occurred
but all of us have had coven before
right we've had well not all of us many
of us i don't want to call everybody out
uh i could speak for myself uh and there
are some you know you still have a dry
cough you still have you know little
sniffles that that last for a little bit
longer
are you saying he or you yeah i'm trying
to get a sense of i am saying that all
of us have had covid many of us have had
coveted before and they tend to be
lingering symptoms and that's what i'm
talking about the president is still
experiencing some things related to his
covet uh course of illness right and
also as we know you all have known him
for some time and covered him he tends
to have a dry cough that is not unusual
so that is what i'm talking about he
tends to have a dry cough which you all
have heard before so just want to be
clear on that too
he's working he's calling and so forth
but to my knowledge i don't believe
you've talked about him getting
extra rest or taking time away from work
has he also had blocks of time where
he's not doing anything so that he can
rest what i can tell you is that he has
been working eight plus hours a day
that is a schedule that he continues to
keep instead of doing it in the oval
office he's doing in the white house
residents
thanks green uh the president suggested
in saudi arabia that there could be an
announcement on oil production coming um
with opec meeting this week is the white
house expecting an increase in oil
production to be announced uh i will
leave that to opec plus we are not a
member of opec plus as you know and so i
i would leave them to answer that answer
whatever they're going to
come coming out of that meeting this
week but the president has received
received no indication and he did make
some strong comments when he was in
saudi arabia about potential good news
and consumers feeling relief again i
leave that to opec oppai class
clarification on how we're counting the
president's days in terms of when he'll
be out of isolation was saturday day
zero or uh saturday day one so i believe
we shared that on on on saturday so what
we shared is is basically what it is
okay
okay all right i'll take one more
question
i'll take one more question i'm going to
try it
right yep and i've called on you before
i'm going to call thanks greg
voters in kansas tomorrow will be the
first in the country since the supreme
court overturned roe v wade to have the
opportunity to vote on an abortion
related ballot measure is the white
house seeing this as a vote that could
have broader political significance
heading into the midterms so if it
passes
tomorrow's vote in kansas could lead to
another state eliminating the right to
choose
and eviscerating access to health care
republican governors and state
legislators are imposing extreme laws
banning a woman's right to choose many
don't allow exceptions even for rape or
incest and congressional republicans are
calling for a national ban on abortion
so president biden has made this very
very clear
that the only way to secure women's
rights to choose is for congress to
restore the protections of roe as
federal law so the majority of americans
we they support that as women's right to
choose and again congress must act as
the president has said many times and it
is also the american people need to make
sure that their voices are heard all
right thanks everybody i'll see you
tomorrow